dude yes sir when we got back from
Oklahoma got an uber from the airport
yeah jump in sky is way too much cologne
our meaning guy boy and [ __ ] what
about me so five you never go to yeah
but he's going whoa but uh my mouth he's
a robo no dude and he's driving through
traffic yeah it's like taking I mean I
very much like they're macho not macho
guys didn't give all [ __ ] hairy arms
oh yeah
dress well there's so much cologne I was
like oh I feel sick he's doing you you
you slopping stunt like oh my and I go
dude is there ain't you I mean no race
to get the boudin to eat our meals swear
live man swear driving I keep
celebrating on Sunday yeah just
celebrating with music so sick time so
interesting I don't know people like
that I don't like when I get in car they
have air freshener air freshener kills
man oh no why if it's real strong yeah
and you can't stand it and then there
are some people that just have no they
like so what if I'm playing music I
don't want to hear it like I don't want
to put my music on your ears I'm some
people could give a [ __ ] they could well
I did a I did a little SBU that show as
for you with the ice iced tea iced tea
and iced tea comes in it's 5:30 in the
morning it's me Chris Maloney and goes
you know actors there these guys are
regulars and Chris Maloney basically I'm
sorry ice-t who's great guy really nice
man but he just puts on his new album at
level 9 at 5:30
hey Lanie Jana said I swear to God I can
write you listen and nobody say they
said she always said check ladies it's
iced tea and he goes and that song goes
that two kinds of [ __ ] in the world
[ __ ] that while you win a [ __ ] or
whatever it was to you but is a Googler
dude and he couldn't be more [ __ ]
macho could not be more modding you
three like I've been saying and [ __ ] man
how this is great - that's right so loud
I was like great music anybody else I
would have been like white turn that
music down right [ __ ] in the hands all
you wanna grab it for this [ __ ] just not
over the tiles with ice-t yeah he's cool
super cool - actually it's kind of
killing it so I you know you see you see
these celebrities and you know in there
like all this is great
eight and these celebrities who come
from a entertainment background they
know the struggle right you know they
have a Writers Guild they have you know
people who fought for them there's these
unions and you know Association to help
them get to where they're at so I think
it's you know it's just not transparent
you know they're busy people so who's
going to sit down and explain to them
and obviously if you're Mike Strahan
you're represent by WME or your Snoop
Dog ribs or dummy WME what do you think
to tell them you think they're giving
them the lowdown no hmm and then also
there's a reason why here Luke Thomas
earlier hewan Eeyore bet on Morocco or
guys in it I was going sorry Brett it's
[ __ ] tough for sure get your last
name either but Brett Ariel Lou Thomas
maybe the big dogs definitely junk you
guys there's a reason why you don't see
the mainstream media as far as I'm sorry
the mainstream MMA media there's a
reason why you don't see them getting
these big interviews with the UFC brass
or there's a reason why I don't see
David going to give energies there's a
reason why I don't see Dana going to
them to talk about Conor McGregor Floyd
because they're going to ask those
ballbusting questions but what what are
you explain to us how the a side is done
and the mainstream media in the u.s. see
mixed martial arts media's going yeah we
know all that do you assume we know all
that so they're gonna ask you the
hard-hitting questions like yeah looking
back on Reebok do you think it's a bad
idea you had a [ __ ] rapper introduce
you to this shoe company you know it's
like that's how this Richard got started
he knows nothing about the sport now you
guys made this huge deal do you do you
looking back on it you know like the the
real journalists are really gonna you're
going to get hit with hard questions so
you never see Danny goose crumbs so he
never see Dana address the media anymore
he goes on a column Tower
he goes on Steven Smith who they know
the very very basics the very very
basics because they're just going to say
man what's it going to take you know
that getting into the nitty-gritty to
the public doesn't want that but because
they just don't know so you go on first
take you go on SportsCenter I mean it
they're tossing up softball
yeah yeah how's this congregating Floyd
Miller thing going on it's all we talked
about now if you're max Holloway
Josie Aldo have you seen any press for
that no nothing for world title in
Brazil Jose Aldo when the greatest
all-time max Haller your next big thing
you know the pride in Hawaii BJ Penn all
these guys Travis brown there's some
[ __ ] monsters out of light Hawaii's a
fighting State have you heard anything
about for max Holloway the in
frustrating must be from XLE we're on TV
and all you see is Conor McGregor
formula which is even doesn't relate to
the UFC really yeah very common for two
dudes do cocaine and start a business
together
oh oh all right you like dude let's
[ __ ] start a video business check it
out even though they're obsolete if we
had video but we go plate think about
this we go plate and we put a
prestigious all of a sudden you know
dude the cauliflower impress these
gold-plated video [ __ ] tapes you're
you you are a coke guy though bruh no no
I just did it a few times I did it
hearty it was you know can I tell you
even this weekend uh we found it rude to
turn down coke like if someone offered
you coke expensive in LA and no grown-up
like in Florida if someone had coke and
they offered you coke that's like on
them going hey man like Gumby district a
wanted to do a line here I'll do a line
I got [ __ ] to do so I'll do like a bump
or something
yeah bump because like a bum turns into
[ __ ] all the cocaine I used to be
really good I'd do just a couple bumps
and be set for the night play some darts
[ __ ] really all those Dargis coke is
I mean really we darts without come we
had one crazy night it was like right
after I start in New York I come back to
Orlando my buddies I won't say their
names but I'll just I owe them a I'll
just say their first names John Brent
and another guy we're all one of them's
got a kid I shouldn't I shouldn't Mike
Jason and and Derek okay they one of the
guys yeah good guys one of them's got a
kid we all hang out and I can't we can
go back to my place and do coke but
listen my I just have this brand-new
baby and my wife
not like she does not know this about me
so if we do yeah yeah let's just lock it
down and and we'll look okay well I
could take the cocaine away from the
baby he's got a dick load and so we're
like Oh Dee put on some Steely Dan put
on some some Frank black something we
can really read into we're about to go
Scarface yeah and it's like it's like
2:00 in the morning we're like this is a
great way to end the night well you know
what we're do this until sunrise or like
a night yeah so start doing it there's a
knock our door all of a sudden it's our
guitar buddy Jason no whatever any but
it doesn't look like Jason it's in an
orchid outfit and he's got an organ
truck out front and he's like hey
understand you guys got a little blow or
like yeah and he's like ah well here's
the deal I don't have any money on me
now but if you can give me a few lines
and maybe a little to take with me I'll
just spray your house with the college's
of this guy we're like a whole like hey
the oldest stories and just do coke with
us like your mom we're bucking up got
high man okay I'm like Jesus you got a
spray I'll take you to your roaches give
me a couple bumps man yeah how pic yeah
but we bring them in and after a few
bumps spraying a house hunt I was a bad
idea
we're like you got more equipment in
there like I do so we all pack up
we all got work in things we're spraying
his house all of a sudden the wife comes
out cuz what a baby and she's like
because one of them's like you got
silverfish and she's like what the [ __ ]
and we look like we are [ __ ]
stormtroopers sitting there without a
joke oh my god silverfish see like
spraying toxic chemicals